okay today I'm going to talk to you
about series circuits so do this I'm
just going to draw a simple circuit
right here so here is an ammeter here is
one filament lamp here is another
filament lamp and here is another
ammeter
so that's what I'm going to do to begin
with so a series circuit the way I
remember it is s is for series s is for
single because there's just a single
root for the electrons to flow around
there's just a single loop in a parallel
circuit there's more than one way for
the electrons flow around but in a
series circuit just one way for the
electrons to flow around now this means
a huge disadvantage of a series circuit
is if I have two filament lamps and
let's say this one breaks that breaks
the whole circuit that means the
electrons can't flow all the way around
the circuit and as a result that bulb
will also go out as well so that's a big
problem with a series circuit another
issue is the more bulbs we put in the
dimmer each bulb will appear and we'll
see why in just a minute so first of all
let's have a look at these a meters so
an ammeter if you remember measures the
the flow of electrons the currents the
flow of charge around the circuit so
anywhere in a series circuit let's say
if this ammeter here read 10 amps then I
know for a fact that this ammeter here a
2 would also read 10 amps because the
current is the same everywhere in a
series circuit we've just got one way
for the electrons to flow one way for
the charge to flow so as a result it's
going to be the same everywhere where it
gets slightly different is when we start
looking at potential difference so let's
imagine this cell here has a potential
difference of 10 volts if I put in this
voltmeter here first of all if I put a
voltmeter in even though volt meters are
connect
in parallel this circuit is still called
a series circuit because the voltmeter
is just there to read the potential
difference so if I've got two volt
meter's in here one around that filament
lamp lamp one round for that film in
that what is the potential difference
going to be for each so in order to do
this it's kind of a good idea to turn
this on the side
so what we're imagining here is as the
charge goes through our cell the cell is
giving it the energy it's as if it's
lifting it up and given energy all of
that energy needs to be transferred
across these two components and that
energy is going to be shared equally
across all of them so if we've got a 10
volt cell all 10 volts need to be evenly
distributed across V 1 and V 2 of course
the first component and the second
component so if I've got a 10 volt cell
v 1 is going to read 5 volts and V 2 is
also going to read 5 volts this is the
reason why the more bulbs you put in the
dimmer they will be because less energy
will be transferred across each
component so that is how currents and
potential difference works in a series
circuit I'm just going to do a really
simple series circuit just underneath
just to show how resistance works
because resistance is probably the
easiest out of everything and how it
works
so remember resistance is what restricts
the current restricts the flow of charge
around the circuit so if I've got this
resistor here let's say that's 3 ohms
and I've got this resistor here which is
2 ohms in order to find the total
resistance in the circuit all you need
to do is 2 plus 3 which is 5 ohms so to
find the resistance in a series circuit
all you need to do is add the resistance
together to find your total so just to
summarize in a series circuit the
current is the same everywhere the
potential difference is shared across
each component and it would be shared
evenly as long
have the same resistance and finally
resistance is calculated just by adding
together the resistance from the
different resistors and that is the
outline of a series circuit thank you